why take the approach of the third party
again this is not a one-party problem
this is uh a problem that's systemic
and so if you were to try and do it
within the democratic party and you play
that out how would that work in red
states and right now if you look at the
states that have ballot initiatives that
allow
one to get
open primaries and rank choice voting on
the ballot a lot of them are red uh the
one state that has already done this is
a deep red state alaska so if you're
going to try and make this happen
in diverse states
that are both red and blue you can't try
and nestle it within in one of the two
parties because then
any other state that you're operating in
will say oh this is like a damn thing or
this is a republican thing as opposed to
something that's
that's that's system-wide
[Music]
hello everyone and welcome to forward
with andrew yang and zach brown man we
are kicking off a new era here on the
podcast we're back man yes and if you
can see us we're in a new space a new
studio that's gonna get swankier and
fancier every single day it's going to
be like one of those uh
i don't know it's like legos you're
watching but it'll get cooler every
episode i think because this is pretty
bare bones the room reading will just go
up and up let's rate my zoom i gotta say
we have so much exciting coming on
the pod it's going to be new format new
equipment we're going to be in person
new guests new a lot of stuff
so i i'm so pumped up i hope you are too
zack and if you're listening to this
this is gonna be a lot of fun we're
gonna have a blast there's a there's a
lot of news happening a lot of things
happening the biggest one is that you're
gonna do the podcast way more often like
you're back you're back in the game
yes
i'm back in the game and it's all part
of the new
plan and vision
and if you've been keeping up with the
news at all uh you know that we're
kicking off a new political movement a
new third party called the forward party
which i discuss at length with crystal
ball
today
but we're also going to be launching a
new media arm and a set of conversations
that hopefully give you
a sense of the future
of solutions but also uplifting
entertaining interesting
and i i can't wait i'm so charged up for
it yeah the so let's start with that you
unpack this with crystal really well but
maybe start for everybody before we dive
in this conversation you're starting a
third party
you've been thinking about this
since before you ran for mayor since um
frankly even towards the end of the
presidential you were seeing a lot of
the plumbing or democracy
not work like these ideas been milling
around your head for a while
maybe
high-level intro like what this is why
you're doing it and what people can
prepare for as they listen to your
interview with crystal
sure thing i spent months writing my
book forward that's out this week uh
please pick up a copy i think you'll
love it and
when i really got into the guts of the
problems in our democracy it was clear
to me that the issues are systemic
and that even if you were successful
within
one of the parties you would not be able
to change what needed to be changed and
so that led me to the conclusion where
it's like okay
you have to try and do something that
people say can't be done
but if you don't do it we're doomed
so and it turns out that everyone wants
someone to do it and one of the things
that has happened over the last number
of years thanks to a lot of the people
listening to this right now is that i
become someone who at least has a
credible shot at doing some big things
in american life and i need to do
everything i can to live
up to and be true to what i think will
solve the problem like what the real
solutions are
and so when you come to that conclusion
you think okay
this is the new direction let's go
i think if the andrew yang legacy is
waking the world up to automation
cash relief slash ubi
and busting up the duopoly that's pretty
good that's a pretty it's pretty good
life
well yeah phase one automation ubi
thank you again everyone thank you zach
without zach uh no one's heard of andrew
yang the next phase is to let folks know
that we we are stuck in a dysfunctional
duopoly uh we're going to remain stuck
and worse we're going to get pitted
against each other the country is going
to continue to disintegrate in various
ways and we all need to get our
together and break up the duopoly enough
so that we can have real
independent points of view and
uh dynamism in our political system and
also make our system more
authoritarianism resistant
and this is something that hit me harder
we're going to talk about this more in
in future episodes zack but if you have
a two-party system and one party gets
hollowed out and overrun by bad
leadership and all the political
incentives are
tied to being
in line with that leader then you can
see
uh democracy crumbling to
authoritarianism pretty quickly right uh
particularly if you go to someone in
that party and say hey you know our
leader is getting a little bit out there
and they'll be like you know who's even
worse those other guys and be like oh
yeah you're right you know we can't so
if you had a
dynamic multi-party system and you had a
party get corrupted then you'd be like
oh that eighth party got a little crazy
uh and and the duopoly and i go into
this and with crystal but like that this
it makes no sense on the face of it uh
it doesn't make any sense given our
founding fathers ambitions and designs
for the country it makes no sense given
the results we're seeing or the
polarization getting worse and worse
so we need to wake our fellow americans
up to the fact that we deserve better we
need better and we can provide better
for ourselves
so
this direction is something i'm
super pumped up about but i want to say
too that
this revolution will take
years
hopefully months but probably years
and one of the things i want to do is
provide folks
a sense of direction and motivation but
also again like that we shouldn't be
stressed out and anxious and at each
other's throats all the time that it's
okay to have some fun and be optimistic
even in the face of very daunting
challenges and a really tough
environment and what so i was talking to
crystal before you like when you're
setting up the interview and
what i love about crystal ball is that
she'll disagree with you you know she's
she's like i don't know about this third
party thing but
i think someone needs to do it so um
i'm interested in this and she doesn't
hold back she asks tough questions but
she asks him in a fair way which i think
is frankly missing in a lot of um media
spins so the conversation's worth it um
we were gonna do our own breakdown of
this and we thought crystal did it
better than anyone could do so no
offense to zach but
she's a pro she's a professional
interviewer and i am not
[Music]
hi everybody very excited to be joined
today by the one and only andrew yang
andrew i know in your book your new book
forward which is the reason for this
conversation you talk about how they
would always introduce you in like the
vagus possible way as businessman
good old businessman andrew yeah
businessman billionaire
now we've yeah exactly tech billionaire
right must be has to be um that's not a
stereotype at all but yeah so now
obviously we've added a lot of other
things to your intro former presidential
candidate former mayoral candidate um
author now of multiple books the latest
one being
forward
no i have a copy too oh and look at this
democracy on the back what does it say
crystal ball
despite being ignored and written off by
mainstream media
no 2020 candidate had more of an impact
in changing our political conversation
then andrew yang thank you crystal i
meant a lot that's true so i bring a
very unbiased perspective to this um no
so i mean my very first question for you
congratulations first of all second of
all
how did you find time to write a book
andrew
i came off the trail in february
uh and then kovit happened and you're
right i was busy during that time
i was a surrogate for joe i started a
non-profit we distributed eight million
dollars
uh i was
podcasting obviously
um
got involved with a number of other
things like a data rights campaign
uh and some anti-asian hate
campaigns
just trying to solve problems during
2020 all while trying to get trump out
of there
but
night would fall my kids would go to bed
at around 9 30 or 10 p.m
and then i would write until 1am is the
way it would go it's like 10 to 1 were
my writing hours crystal uh and then i'd
get up you know a little bit sluggish a
little bit late
but i tried to make the most of
last year because coming off the
presidential trail i knew that there
were some experiences i really wanted to
capture and document
and i wanted to get them while they were
fresh so i i got to writing really in
march
and i wrote every if not every day
certainly every week uh through the
entirety of last year
i have to think also
um
you know i did not run for president but
i did run for congress and so i have
just the tiniest taste of what it's like
after that campaign ends and the sort of
like the adrenaline of that and the
emotional rollercoaster of that and
these
incredible highs and lows that you're
experiencing on a daily basis when that
all goes away
it also seems to me like this was
probably really good way for you to kind
of like work through what that
experience was all about and also just
to keep yourself on track and super busy
your schedule is already packed but you
decided to pack it in even more
yeah it was very useful processing and
reflecting and it was a whirlwind on the
presidential trail i did very little
reflecting
when i was running that's for sure it
was just okay what needs to happen right
now uh where are we going what's the
media appearance what's the event what's
the rally
and then when the campaign ended
i was
wiped out frankly
but i also felt this real obligation to
try to
keep the movement going and growing
because i felt so indebted to the people
that had supported me and when i
suspended my campaign a lot of people
were very upset
and that hurts too because you know you
see all these messages and you're
getting all these messages and so i
wanted to make good on what i felt like
was the promise of the campaign
uh certainly i'm really proud that it
felt like we really
advanced the cause of cash relief where
when the 1200 checks first started going
out i got dozens of press requests being
like do you feel like you've been proven
right and i always tried to say that
it's really all thanks to the yang gang
and the folks who supported us but i
heard from dozens of members of congress
who said to me that they thought that
our campaign was a reason why cash was
front and center they said that without
us it might not have
been as ready as solution
i don't think there's any doubt about
that i also don't think there's any
doubt that of the various um stimulus
measures that were taken during the
pandemic direct cash aid
was the most effective it certainly
seems like the research bears that out
it also was the thing that our
government was most able to handle um
dignitaries
didn't create a lot of needless you know
like right now we're dealing with we had
this eviction moratorium there was aid
passed to help renters be able to stay
in their homes to help make sure that
you know small landlords were kept whole
as well in the process and such a tiny
sliver
of that went out because it fell to
state and local governments there were a
million hoops for renters to be able to
jump through to get that aid so
it really did sort of prove out your
thesis that look this is the most
straightforward approach and it's also
the most effective approach i think we
really saw that this year it's
infuriating how little of the rental aid
got out i think right now it's at 17 8
months in uh 2.6 million families are
potentially going to get evicted and so
our government
allocated the money
but it just wasn't able to get to the
people that needed it because the fact
is if state and local governments don't
get it into your hands
nothing bad happens to them it's like oh
like you know 83 of it still sitting in
an account somewhere uh while people's
lives are being
disrupted and
kids are being traumatized the whole
thing really should make us all angry
and i think you were one of the people
that talked about how when the cares act
first came out
that
so much of it went into the hands of
megacorps and institutions and i think
the numbers i saw said that less than 18
percent of it actually went to people
and families
which is a recurring theme
and
if you have 2.2 trillion you could
conceivably have given every american a
thousand bucks a month for six months uh
which i'm going to suggest probably
would have made a lot of americans much
happier
than what what we did do
uh which was uh send money in every
direction but to toward the people that
needed it
yeah and it's also just a respectful
solution it's you know giving people the
respect of believing that they know what
to do with that money that they're going
to spend it wisely which again the
research has shown and borne out time
and time again um there are a million
things i want to get to with you i have
so many questions for you um but we'll
be here all right crystal
i won the first three-hour podcast there
you go
we'll go joe rogan style we'll go you
know three hours three and a half hours
no problem no i want to jump into the
big news making from this book which is
that you announce
that you are launching the forward party
you announce the planks of that it is a
third party you're sort of giving up on
the democratic party or so it would seem
and striking out on your own talk to me
about what the forward party is all
about and how you came to the decision
that a third party is a better pathway
than trying to reform the democratic
party from within
one important thing to to know crystal
and i'd love to hear what you thought
about the book because i haven't really
spoken to you about it but i i wrote
this book in 2020 late at night
like reflecting on my journey and what i
had experienced and what i thought the
real problems were
and
in that process i learned a lot and i
read books
uh by jonathan height and lawrence
lessig and ezra klein and catherine gail
and michael porter and all these other
books because i was trying to put my
finger on
something that that had been nagging at
me
uh through the process
and
we're right now we're being set up to
fail truly there are different people
who are listening to this who have
different feelings about the democratic
party and its efficacy but i would
actually look at the rental aid
program as a microcosm of what's going
on in our government
where if you have a program in that case
you dedicated tens of billions of
dollars to a renter's aid and it doesn't
get to anyone what happens what happens
to our leaders
absolutely nothing what happens to the
bureaucrats who are meant to administer
the program absolutely nothing like
nothing happens the connection between
us and our representatives is not what
we want it to be and not what most of us
believe it to be
and so
when i was researching this book
i found that there are a bunch of truths
that
most of us
ignore
like the fact that
only 10 percent of americans are
essentially responsible for electing 83
of our representatives uh like the fact
that
overall approval of congress is at 28
now and the re-election rate for
individual reps is 92 percent
i'm actually curious crystal in your
congressional race what was the dynamic
was it an incumbent like who are you
running against
yes i was running
against an incumbent in a very
conservative district of virginia he's
actually still there republican who's
still there and uh it was during 2010 so
the tea party wave so i was running as a
progressive in a conservative district
against an incumbent amazing timing
amazing like you can just tell walking
into it i had no idea what i was getting
myself into and i guess in a way that
was that was kind of the beautiful part
of it because if i had known i never
would have actually done it
but um
so much of
i think especially in particular at the
house level
so much of the dynamics are just
how's the district drawn is it open seat
or incumbent things that what is the
national mood overall things that have
literally zero to do
with you or your campaign
how hard you work or what you want to
bring the issue set that you want to
bring to the american people
so your district at the time was r plus
oh
this is a long time ago now i want to
say it was our plus
12.
wow so that that's a very daunting i
mean this is landscape for you trump
wins like 60 some percent in this
district
so your race in some ways is uh is an
emblem
of this crystal where the incumbent that
you lost to is still there 11 years
later doing his thing and
any democrat
who runs a against him is doomed in that
district as it's currently drawn you're
phenomenally talented i'm sure 11 years
ago you were awesome um but to your
point not awesome 11 years ago but i was
doing my best i was very earnest and i
was working hard yes but but to your
point anyone could have run and they
would have lost under the democratic
ticket that republican member of
congress only has one concern and it's
getting primaried
so what what you see is very powerful
incentives that will drive a republican
in that situation to want to placate the
10 to 20 percent most extreme voters in
his or her district which is one reason
why you see so little
dissent from trump because if someone
says hey trump doesn't speak for me then
all of a sudden you'll be out of there
because
the most extreme 20
of
republican voters in that district and
around the country are going to get rid
of you like that so we have very very
strong incentives to drive people toward
the extremes uh to some extent on both
sides right now i i believe it's a much
bigger problem on the republican side on
the democratic side there are also
distortions though where you have
special interests that are much more
involved in the process because they
have a lot at stake
and so they're there in the most extreme
17 to 20 percent of democratic primary
voters
so the the system right now
will not lead us to positive results and
so coming to that conclusion
myself and one thing i pride myself on
is just being intellectually honest is
like okay
if this is the conclusion i've drawn
then what's a true answer and the answer
i found was we need to change the closed
party primary system to open primaries
and rank choice voting to change the
incentives so that our legislators
aren't trying to please the most extreme
but instead are trying to please 51
and that would transform incentives
overnight
all of that so in terms of the solution
of ranked choice voting and uh open
primaries or jungle primaries are
sometimes called i think that that all
logically makes a lot of sense because
then you also don't get in the situation
of like you know during your primary i'm
sure there are a lot of people who
wanted to vote for you who are excited
about what you had to offer but weren't
convinced that you could win and they
didn't want to quote unquote waste their
vote and so if you have a ranked choice
system then people don't have to worry
about that or same thing with bernie or
any other number of candidates who
people could have felt like let me just
actually vote for the candidate i really
like and i'm not wasting my voice vote
i'm not serving as a spoiler or any of
that so all of that makes a lot of sense
to me
[Music]
we're all human we all get down
sometimes and one of the things that a
lot of us do is nothing
which is not what you want to do so
what's something that fits your needs is
confidential is convenient so where do
you turn
there is a service that we recommend
here at the pod it's better help and
this is connecting you to a professional
licensed therapist you can talk
confidentially you can ping them anytime
you need them
and they'll get you on the schedule it's
convenient it's professional it's
affordable it is awesome
we swear by it we want you to be happier
we want ourselves to be happier
and
if you go there right now you'll get 10
off your first month by visiting our
sponsor betterhelp.com
yang join over 1 million people who have
improved their mental health again
that's better help help
calm yang love them they're going to
help you
[Music]
um there's two questions i have for you
well probably more than two but we'll
start with two questions for you
on the approach specifically which is
everything you've described is like
a not so much a democratic party problem
or republican party problem right and
lord knows i'm not a defender
really of either of those parties but
what you're describing isn't necessarily
a specific problem with either of those
parties it's a problem with the system
written it's an incentives problem it
just it's a straightforward
systemic problem so why start a third
party to address that
why not you know
get the democratic party to push for it
or have an outside organization that's
that's pushing for a reform movement or
getting this question on the ballot in
different states so that they could pass
their reforms that way why take the
approach of the third party
again this is not a one-party problem
this is uh a problem that's systemic
and so if you were to try and do it
within the democratic party and you play
that out how would that work in red
states
and right now if you look at the states
that have ballot initiatives that allow
one to get
open primaries and ranked choice voting
on the ballot a lot of them are red
the one state that has already done this
is a deep red state alaska and i do want
to illustrate how this works in real
life
lisa murkowski the senator from alaska
is the only republican senator who's up
for re-election in
2022 that voted to
impeach donald trump her approval rating
among alaska republicans is now six
percent uh it's literally a political
suicide for someone to do what senator
murkowski did
but alaska just changed their primaries
to be open primaries and ranked choice
voting last year so now senator
murkowski actually doesn't go through a
strictly republican primary she goes to
everyone and so she has a fighting
chance to be reelected now does that
incentive change have something to do
with her decision to impeach trump i'm
going to suggest probably
i'm going to suggest that that's
probably the case so if you're going to
try and make this happen
in diverse states
that are both red and blue you can't try
and nestle it within in one of the two
parties because then
any other state that you're operating in
will say oh this is like a dem thing or
this is a republican thing right as
opposed to something that's
that's that system wanted i get that too
i get that too but of course you also
know the history of third parties in the
country which is
you know as hard as it is to get things
changed through the existing parties
the best modern day performance we've
had for a third party presidential
candidate of course is ross perot he
didn't win a single state um there are
already existing third party at the
liberty crystal because you often say
like you're kind of shooting towards
what what a lot of people have done
which is something that i want to pull
back from which is people just fast
forward to the presidential i mean like
to to me
uh i'm not thinking about that at all
i'm thinking about what we can do to try
and make our legislators incentives
better right now or right now in in real
terms right now means november 2022
and so if you're trying to get that done
you could say hey let's start an
organization around this which i think
is a great idea um some organizations
are doing that work and i'm trying to do
my best to help them
but if you're going to ignite a true
popular movement around this you need to
raise something of like a
flag to join uh you know um and so
that's why i believe that you need this
popular movement that by the way is
inclusive of registered democrats you do
not need to change your party
registration to sign up with a forward
party if you're a republican who's sick
of it you can sign up with a forward
party and keep your republican
registration because i'm a practical guy
changing your party registration would
disenfranchise you in eighty percent of
these districts like why would you do
that right
so
where we're a
popular movement that's going to be
inclusive but i think a lot of people
that are most excited about this are
people that think that the party system
is broken and if you rewind this duopoly
we're in is a nightmare of the founding
fathers come to life that has lasted for
130 years it makes zero sense on the
face of it
they were anti-partisanship they wanted
shifting coalitions and factions the uk
has five political parties sweden has
eight political parties netherlands has
18 political parties we're stuck with
two
by the way if you are going to have a
system where you have two major parties
you know what could happen
hypothetically one of them succumbs to
terrible leadership and then our systems
aren't prepared to actually try and
check that because guess what the
founders didn't imagine that there'd
only be two political parties
so there are so many problems with the
current system the way it's set up and
we're just going to drive ourselves
crazy until we get to the bottom of
those problems everything else is just
going to be like praying for things to
change when when you really dig into it
there is no reason to expect it to
change it'll get worse the polarization
will get worse the dysfunction will get
worse uh and we're going to be looking
up being like why aren't things changing
this is the way we actually change it
so layout for me what the plan is
what are you thinking of in terms of the
midterms will you be fielding candidates
will you be pushing for ballot access
just talk me through sort of like the
plan of what this looks like in the near
term
i love it because this is another
misconception crystal again we're smart
we're practical we want to get great
stuff done the pillars of the forward
party start with open primaries and
ranked choice voting so someone needs to
be for those things but they also
include things i think a lot of your
listeners are huge supporters of like
universal basic income
human-centered economy
fact-based governance
modern and effective government and this
is something that you really have to
stand up for which is we talking these
arguments
passing
relief when nothing when only 17 of it
gets to people
is a moral failure like someone should
be held accountable for that but we
actually aren't paying attention to
whether the pipes work it's just oh i
stood up i did something and then we go
home while people are left wondering why
the system's not working um and the the
last pillar is grace intolerance which
is to me
one of the things that's necessary to
try and bring the country back together
like we're getting set up to attack each
other we're getting set up to regard our
fellow americans as mortal enemies
and it's a recipe for disaster so if
someone is for these six pillars and
they're running as a democrat in a
primary or running as a republican in a
primary let's get behind them you know
like you don't need to run as forward
party we're going to be a group that
just supports people who are for these
principles
and simultaneously we will be activating
voters to pass these ballot initiatives
to try and implement open primaries and
rank choice voting in states around the
country
gotcha so this sounds a little bit like
the um
the dsa model in that they'll back
candidates who are running on the
democratic party line they also do field
candidates who run you know outright as
dsa candidates but they've they've
focused electorally and had some success
that way in backing candidates who are
running as democrats but support their
shared values is that kind of like the
the realm of what you're thinking in
yes because again we're we're smart and
impact driven and in a lot of these
locations it is
impossible to run as anything other than
a democrat and republican so we're going
to support people who are aligned
regardless of what letters next to their
name
so one other thing i wanted to ask you
about is um you talk in the book
quite a lot about
uh the extremes and the incentives
within the party
within both the parties to sort of move
to the far edges of those parties and
the way that just as you said you know
you're not really worried about someone
from the other party challenging you
you're worried about your primary
challenge or if you're in one of these
many many many safe districts
how do you define extreme though because
it struck me as i was reading this a lot
of people would have said that you
running on universal basic income that
that was extreme or that was radical or
that was a french idea so when you're
talking about party extremism some
people would say you know health care
for everyone is extreme even though
we're the only developed country that
doesn't do that um some people would say
raising taxes on corporations is extreme
even though 80 of americans support that
right so when you're talking about
extremism just what what do you mean by
that language
it's playing out differently in the two
parties and i i think on the republican
side we can see what's going on where
you have people who are hardcore trump
supporters completely dominating uh the
party primaries and making it so that
the republican party really is just a
vessel for trump
and i know there are many longtime
republicans who are looking up saying
huh like you know like this is not what
i thought the party was but here we are
on the democratic side
it's a bit different and i referenced it
a little bit earlier is that there are
people and i'm for different policies i
as you saw in the book i'm for
healthcare for all i think it's common
sense and we need it i'm obviously for
universal basic income
um but on the democratic side what you
see is that there are special interests
um that have outsized influence in the
process in part because it is a closed
party primary so this could be teachers
unions it could be big pharma it could
be different groups that
have
a very very high stake
in what happens uh from leadership and
there there is some ideological shift
too that happens uh on that side but i
think the different influences the
parties struggle with are different
i'm going to suggest that regardless
having to appeal to 51 of voters would
be an improvement uh
regardless of which party you're talking
about
[Music]
one of the parts in the book that i
thought was really interesting is you
talk about how
um this isn't exactly your language so i
don't want to you know i don't want to
twist your words here but you're sort of
talking about how power changes people
and how power corrupts which is of
course you know something that is a an
old adage um and the other thing that i
was thinking about as i was reading that
is people who
are in support of moving away from the
democratic party and towards a third
party they oftentimes will say
you may go in to change the democratic
party but the democratic party is
ultimately going to change you
what was your experience with that i
mean you didn't end up as the nominee
but you certainly had a lot of a lot of
people who really believed in you these
huge events these huge rallies
hundreds of thousands of people donating
i mean i don't know maybe millions lots
of people donating to your campaign
millions of dollars flowing in
did you find it hard to
remain yourself did you feel yourself
influenced by that sort of newfound fame
and and modicum of power
i do write a chapter uh about this but i
think the biggest
problem is when someone shows up in dc
and even if you're raring to go and you
want to change things
you're looking at a seniority system and
people who've been there for
20 25 30 years who are in power and so
the natural approach you're gonna end up
with is divide your time and to to be
there for a while and say yeah you know
it'll be my time eventually
now for me personally i'm kind of an odd
duck crystal i don't know i mean like
running for president was
uh
was
like an act of activism on my part i
thought i could help
educate us about what's going on with
our economy and accelerate the adoption
of universal basic income in the end of
poverty in our time
and strangely enough i never expected to
get recognized on the street
[Laughter]
in a way it didn't make any sense um and
i think part of it has to do with uh
being an asian guy where like i joke in
the book that like you know asian guys
feel like we have like an invisibility
cloak where if we just like you know
don't try to draw attention to ourselves
that people will just totally ignore us
and so
uh even now
um
you know i i don't oh i mean i could
make a joke now it's like i'm not very
proud because i don't run anything which
is pretty accurate
but but certainly
and you you might have had this
experience lately because i know um in
some ways uh you know your popularity
has been growing very quickly
um getting recognized in public is a
trip like that that's weird um but
what's funny crystal is that even though
it's happened to me over and over again
like i still act like it's the first
time when it happens when it's like oh
like what do you want a picture sure
like um
i i do think the problem is if someone
winds up in dc and is there for years it
will
distort you over time even if you
entered with the best of intentions it's
one reason why i'm for
18-year term limits in each house of
congress
we have to try and do something about
this geritocracy it is not good for the
country to have
uh 75 80 80 you know geez like you know
octogenarians running things especially
if you believe as i do that technology
is one of the major forces in american
life that we have to try to
address the excesses of because our
leaders don't understand technology
natively
especially if they got there 30 years
ago
what has been the response
from the democratic party establishment
i mean you endorsed joe biden you went
and campaigned for him you went and
campaigned very hard in georgia you ran
for mayor of new york as a democrat
something else i want to get to and ask
you more about so they've definitely
assumed you're fully in their camp
you're got their back you're on their
side have you gotten much of a response
from them have they been surprised have
they been disappointed have they been
supportive from some of those folks who
are in the sort of upper echelons of the
democratic party
i i've gotten various text messages
messages from members of congress uh you
know they've been inquisitive would be i
suppose that the word i'd use um but the
people who are texting me know what
motivates me know what's in my heart not
you know i'm just trying to do the best
i can
um i think that there's
uh some curiosity around it for sure and
uh you know i think also that people in
the press have been sensationalizing in
a particular way
hopefully even this conversation will
make people feel like okay like i see
where he's going and this makes sense i
mean we need a popular movement to
address the structural
incentive problems in our system or else
we're going to just drive ourselves
crazy uh and the the craziness is going
to result in political violence uh it's
going to result in a recurrence of
you know some unthinkable things that
we've seen over the last number of
months
i want to be the leader of the
anti-polarization movement uh the the
forward party and so i think a lot of
democrats right now are kind of waiting
and seeing uh how it plays out but i
have gotten messages some of them you
know are from friends and then they say
that one of them said like look i'm
really sorry to see you go
um but
uh that they
believe that i'll be back in in some
form in the sense not rejoining the
democratic party necessarily
[Laughter]
i'll see them um because people that are
trying to make positive things happen
just end up
um
around each other a lot
would you ever run for president again
as a democrat
right now i'm focused on
getting the forward party up and running
to a point where we're excited about
candidates at 22 and these ballot
initiatives uh you know i'm just going
to try my best to maximize my own impact
in the time we have crystal like we
don't have unlimited time i mean our
democracy is
disintegrating and like we have to take
it very very seriously
and try and bust ass as quickly as we
can
uh i don't have some deep native desire
to
uh hold a particular office i don't have
some burning ambition
like i'm going to do whatever i think is
best for the country
uh you know if there's a need i can
fulfill i'll certainly take a look at it
but you know i i don't have any designs
past trying to get some bald initiatives
passed in 22 and hopefully getting some
candidates across the finish line
so one of the things you talked about in
your presidential campaign and also talk
about in the book is the sort of
corruption of money in politics both
when you're
running for office and you're having to
solicit all these donations then you get
into office and the first thing you got
to do is dial for dollars again and go
meet with lobbyists and raise money from
lobbyists and that whole cycle not to
mention
um and we see this i would say with
kirsten cinema right now you know
pushing back against the reconciliation
bill at the same time that she's running
raising money from the very corporate
interest that would benefit from that
bill being killed at the same time
you're looking towards okay when i get
out of congress then i'm going to get a
cushy gig in the private sector for x
and y and z company so let me make sure
i'm happy with them they're happy with
me
while i'm here in the people's house so
you talk about
that rot and that corruption
and how corrosive it is to and how it
messes up the incentives of
people who may be genuinely good people
who want to serve and end up not doing
what they set out to do once they get to
washington
um how will you protect the forward
party to make sure that it's not subject
to that same sort of corrosive impact of
money in politics
you know i got asked as the other day
crystal and my immediate response was
who on earth would donate to the forward
party
uh because we don't run anything
like if you're a big corporate it's like
let me get behind the forward party
because they're really gonna lower my
taxes you know the only people who would
donate to ford are people that want to
see our democracy actually live up to
that name
uh that they want a system that will
have our legislators answered a majority
of us instead of uh the most ideological
minority
now if we're running the the show
then i would love to have another
conversation with you about how we're
going to make sure that the forward
party doesn't get overrun by corporate
donors because uh we're looking at you
know
innovative ways to do that um
but right now i mean it really is sort
of funny in the sense that and like no
one rational would donate
to the board party for
uh for self-serving reasons because it
just wouldn't make any sense
i think you saw yourself a little short
there though because you know you're a
very influential person and you have a
big following so
it's not crazy to me to imagine that
there would be people or interests who
would love to have access to that i mean
first for some of these people like to
throw you a hundred thousand dollars or
whatever it's nothing to them why not
place a bet on this thing even if it is
a long shot chance
well if they do that and and uh it pays
off then you know we'd be happy to
publicly disclose all the people that
have donated to us and then we can have
a conversation as to what the future
holds
um but
i i would have to say it would take a
real
uh visionary with a very long time
horizon to do it for bad reasons
[Laughter]
maybe you're maybe i am selling myself
short crystal maybe i'm cool enough
where people just throw money at it to
hang out with me um
you know everybody's cool enough to be
subject to these influence i mean as you
point out a lot of this isn't about
sometimes in the commentary it can get
very much caught up on individual
personalities and like this person is
sold out and that person is corrupt and
people have agency and they deserve
blame for those things but we're all
human and like we're all subject to
these sort of corrosive influences i see
it in my own work you know one of the
things that we tried to do with our
business model is protect ourselves from
being too driven by the youtube
algorithm or by what's going to be
monetized or not by youtube because look
i know i'm a human being i know when i
was at msnbc and they told me hey next
time you say something mean about
hillary clinton you got to run it by us
i know that impacted the way that i
covered her so i just i have a lot of
humility i know you do too about how
we're all subject to these influences
even when we have the best of intentions
i'm with you for sure and i think that's
the big lesson about our current system
crystal it's one reason why again we're
all pulling our hair out wondering why
it's not getting any better the system
is fundamentally corruptive
and then what we're doing is we're
pretending that certain people are good
and uh not cropped and though those
people are corrupt and then someone's
like oh that person's a hypocrite that
the system is dirty the system is making
it so that reasonable person can enter
and then try their best out try their
heart out but they'll be there grinding
and dialing for dollars someone that
gives to them is going to represent some
corporate interest and i like that
that's the way our system is designed
and that the best thing we can do right
now is to try and clean up our system so
that it actually is more responsive to
popular will
uh and this is the best way to do so
so i'm with you 100 uh i think it was a
quote from ezra klein in his book that i
quote in in my book
that uh
corruptive systems overcome good
individuals with ease
and and that's what we're seeing over
and over again we're wondering why it's
not working
[Music]
i'm a huge fan of trying to do what
we're designed to do as humans and you
know what we're not designed to do stare
at a screen all day which is
unfortunately what a lot of us are doing
and as a result we're getting eye strain
we're getting headaches and i am happy
to say that there is a solution for this
felix gray glasses are the blue light
glasses that started it all they filter
out 15 times more of the blue light so
that you can stare at a screen all day
if you have to
and actually be perfectly healthy i know
it sounds too good to be true i'm
actually friends with the founders of
this company and i am pumped to be able
to recommend them on the pond because
they work they like it's it's generally
they look good too freaking awesome the
glasses are either non-prescription or
prescription whatever you like get them
at felix grayglasses.com yang that's f e
l i x g r a y glasses dot com slash yang
free shipping free returns free
exchanges felixsgrayglasses.com
yang again personally recommend them
know the founders great builders great
company great product gonna keep you
healthier which is something i love to
do you know again we don't wanna have to
stare at these things but we gotta so
might as well be healthy doing it
[Music]
so i wanted to ask you a little bit more
about some of the planks because i i
think they're really interesting and um
you you mentioned how grace intolerance
is one of the ones that you find to be
sort of most critical and most vital
that's something that really resonates
with me because i do think we
um
we have a situation right now where
people feel very impotent they feel like
uh they did the thing they were supposed
to do they voted for the right candidate
so they got out there and organized or
they gave their 10 bucks or whatever
and they're still not able to see that
change in that progress that they've
been wanting to now for years and years
and so
i think a lot of people not a lot of
people but some people turn
that sense of impotence and the way that
they can find power is by well let me
judge this person let me shame this
person let me call this person out let
me be full of condemnation
rather than hey how do we build
solidarity how do we build a cohesive
movement that can actually effectuate
change so
talk to me a little bit about when i see
grace intolerance that's what i think
about but talk to me about what you
think about when you put those two words
into your um party platform
well one thing i think about are my
family members who voted for trump uh
and i still love them and hold them dear
even though they voted for trump
uh
to your point there's so much pain and
suffering and rage and it's manifesting
in different ways in different quarters
it's legitimate it's real
one of the things i want to do is try
and channel all of that energy into
something that's productive and
solutions oriented that's what the
forward party hopes to do
but the grace intolerance i was thinking
about really is just to try to embrace
our shared humanity and our fall ability
and that that and our difference uh one
of the points i make in the book
um is that a lot of people's politics
are born of circumstances they did not
have any control over
um and so then
despising them for that um is not
one it's not helpful but it's also not
acknowledging their
uh their humanity in the same way i mean
i grew up with people of uh who were
uh
i grew up with a lot of italian
americans in upstate new york
and
uh you know i got um
picked on a fair amount as one of the
lone asian kids in my school
um
and
no like looking at those people now i
mean i haven't seen them all uh and
whatnot i mean like we were
probably in very different places
politically but
you know like you you still
shared so much uh time and experiences
with them and uh it's
it's something that's gotten lost now
the ideological barriers particularly in
a two-party system where it becomes good
versus evil on both sides um
then
we're never going to get anywhere and
we're going to end up ginning up the
engines of personal destruction
we're just going to keep on having this
rise and fall
of just about everyone who raises their
hand and tries to do something positive
and then
the people that are going to to end up
riding various waves are going to be not
the people you want
so that way like if they're
just
waves of negative emotion then the
people that will harness those waves are
going to be not super
uh productive uh individuals so
it's hopefully an antidote to that
hopefully saying look
i disagree with you on a lot of things
but you're still a human being uh you
know like i screw up i'm still a human
being um i try and put in the book
various episodes of my screwing up as a
parent or partner or friend or boss or a
candidate or whatever it is
um and
i know like it's you get up and do the
best you can the next day i think that
if we can
forgive
ourselves and each other then we'll have
a much better chance at getting some
positive change done than if we're
really really
intent on trying to pick people apart
and find the worst in each other yeah i
mean i 100 agree with that do you see
that as mostly like a um an ethos a sort
of moral value or do you think that
there are actual policy choices that we
could make that would help to create
that culture
the biggest policy choice we could make
is open primaries and right choice
voting because then all of a sudden
you'd have really diverse points of view
and no one could bully you for wasting
your vote and you know like people could
show up and
um and you'd have a much higher level of
dynamism
and the incentives would be towards a
higher degree of reasonableness because
if you put a reasonable legislator in
there and say hey cater to the 20
most extreme and polarized voters in
your district guess what they're going
to sound more unreasonable
so when you talk about something that'll
actually make us more reasonable you
have to set up incentives that reward
reasonableness that's what i hope the
forward party becomes we're like the
reward for reasonableness like the the
uh
the wet blanket that will bring the
temperature down andrew yang america's
wet blanket uh you know it's like
something along those lines like we just
gotta
kind of get people focused on things
that are actually gonna help us is right
now and ezra klein says this it says
that right now we're that we're just
feeding cycles of political rage that
are leading to madness
um why do you think it is
that
you write about how when you're running
for president in particular you'd meet
someone maybe they were a trucker and
obviously you spoke a lot too that was a
big thing truckers for yang and you did
ride-alongs and you talked a lot about
the future of the trucking industry
maybe you meet a trucker and immediately
when you say i'm a democrat it's like
switch flips they're not interested you
know suddenly you've gone from being an
interesting fellow human to some other
thing um
where do you think that comes from how
did that happen
i think that comes from the fact that we
have these polarized media columns when
i say column i mean you know you have
fox on the right and an msnbc on the
left and then cnn somewhere in the
leftish middle
i suppose if you were to characterize it
uh and so that trucker um has probably
listened to a lot of talk radio because
he's a trucker
so
he has something of a caricature of the
democratic party in his head
um and the most extreme statements of
the democratic party have probably been
piped into his truck
by
contemptuous talk radio host for a long
time and so then when andrew yang shows
up at his truck stop and says hey i'm
running for president as a democrat
they're like democrat um but
unfortunately i got that not just at the
truck stop but in the in the
store
in the diner
uh on the street
uh and and this again is one of the
problems i mean we're rewarding our
media outlets for
ginning us up um on both sides
uh and that's where
all of the
money lies really uh you know again i
mean we'll see you and sagar doing a
great job of this but like i'm hoping
that there's an audience uh
in rationality and reasonableness and
solutions
uh you know i'm sure i'd make a lousy
uh
trucking talk radio host
maybe they'd be into it i mean i should
i should i should yeah i should i
shouldn't sell myself short again but um
but the media incentives end up driving
us toward these extremes crystal and i
think that's why people react so
negatively to each other on both sides
could you talk a little bit more about
the media because you also have some
great anecdotes in the book about um i'd
love if you if you tell people the
wingding episode and i'll just set it up
for folks a little bit so you go to iowa
you get invited it's early in the
campaign you're going to this big
democratic party function called the
wingding it's you
john delaney tim ryan and
michael avenatti
and
i'll let you take it from there but i
think this episode sort of sums up
what political coverage and political
quote-unquote journalism actually is
yeah so i feel a lot of pressure uh
because it's like my first big political
speech and like a thousand iowans there
and i'm like oh my gosh i have to knock
this out of the park
um so
john delaney speaks tim ryan speaks i
speak and then michael avenatti speaks
and i thought he was awful like he was
just reading
and he went over along and it was boring
and i was like this is terrible
and then he comes off of the stage and
he's surrounded by a dozen political
reporters and cameras who are peppering
him with various questions journalists i
did not even know were in the room uh
and they just followed michael avenatti
around
um for a number of minutes
and then
wrote up
articles about how michael avenatti
excites the iowans and a bunch of other
things
and i was there and i was like what the
heck just happened like you know like i
thought he was terrible and
um and the write-ups did not mention
me or john or tim for the most part uh
and so there was a sense it's like wow
the story had already been written like
they showed off they were just gonna be
like gavin audi excites the iowans
right
and that's why
themselves
whether they responded or not was sort
of irrelevant
yes and what i think that happened was
that they would find you know an ion r2
who would give a positive quote and by
the way you could have gotten positive
quotes about any of us from iowans
because iowans are very nice
very nice they could have been andrew
gagging's iowans where was that story
but
this is like the first major brush and
it's so
uh jarring because obviously avenatti
was a total flim flam
like cogman
and the fact that he was getting
elevated that way um next to two
candidates who already declared in me
and john
and then tim was certainly going to
declare um but the media was not there
for any of us
um so what do you think
is the sort of
what's the solution there because this
is one i struggle with i mean obviously
i'm trying to offer my own solution just
through my show which i have to say it's
a little self-serving but
it does give me hope that we have an
audience that is truly ideologically
diverse
that sagar and i certainly have
different views on things that
people stick with us our audience sticks
with us even when we say things that
they may disagree with at times like
that does make me hopeful
that there's an appetite for something
different but if the media is such an
issue and driving so much um
sectarianism which is really what it is
what is the solution for that because
they're not going to change you know
they profit off a crisis they profit off
of political violence they never had
higher ratings than they did on january
6. that was great for business trump was
great for business
so how do you get out of that cycle
well i have some ideas in my book um but
i'm also a huge fan of breaking points
in you and sagar and i think that you
are truly the answer
uh not not to put pressure on you but um
but when i say you i mean uh truly
independent viewpoints that are free of
uh corporate media that develop
followings because people begin to trust
you i have a theory crystal that in the
new world people won't trust
institutions so much as they'll trust
people people trust you people trust
sauger i hope some of them trust me
um and so that the goal is then to build
a constellation of trusted voices who
can be
voices of reason and moderation and
reasonableness even if you have like you
said i mean you can have very dramatic
policy wishes
um
like giving everyone money i mean you
know that used to be
seem very extreme but uh but that you
try and traffic in reality and uh you
know let you you
uh don't make up your own facts and you
try and treat other people in a certain
way and people grow to trust your
viewpoint um now the question is can you
and sagar uh and some of these other
independent voices become true rivals to
the media networks i believe you can
truly
um
and i'd like to be a part of that i have
some ideas on the
cable news front i suggest in the book
that we should bring back the fairness
doctrine which existed until the reagan
years that just said if you present one
side of a point of view then you should
present the other two not 50 50 but just
like have some moderation
and the fcc used to have authority over
that and then they got rid of that and
then lo and behold uh fox and msnbc
came up very shortly thereafter
[Music]
you know that's actually of course
during the reagan years is when we
totally took the breaks off and clinton
continued it too by the way and and went
to this model of
wildly unfettered capitalism
where you know the only value that we're
really leaning into is the value of
money the value of profit margins what
you call for in the forward parties what
you call human-centered capitalism
talk to me about what you mean by that
because in some ways i almost feel like
those two words human-centered and
capitalism are at odds with each other
if you're looking at capitalism just as
making money profit margin because you
certainly see that in our health care
system since we've put the profit
margins at the center of everything it
means we don't get good health care we
don't even have that as a value within
the system so talk to me about what you
mean by that phrase
what i mean is
an economy where we're actually
measuring ourselves as the unit of
progress like our quality of life our
physical health our mental health our
education rates are clean air and clean
water
we should be reporting on those numbers
much more diligently than
stock market prices or gdp growth or
headline unemployment and if you looked
at those numbers you would see that
we're at 28th in the world
in
public education clean air and clean
water infant mortality all these basics
and we shouldn't accept that no like if
you have our level of wealth and
resources and kids are dying
unnecessarily and
we're failing so many in our education
system
uh it should be reported on all the time
and you know if you saw it you'd see
that mental illnesses uh are spiking
like what good is
uh high gdp if your kids are anxious and
depressed all the time which by the way
is a byproduct in part of of social
media and the rest of it so that's what
i mean by human-centered capitalism is
that we are the point of the economy not
the fuel
and so if you measure human progress
uh then you'd see that we've been
failing and falling down for a long time
um i wanted to ask you a little bit
about the mayoral race there were plenty
of autopsies of you know why you started
on ahead and didn't end up uh pulling
through in the end i gave my own
thoughts on the matter what was your
sort of assessment of what went wrong
there and why you weren't able to
ultimately prevail
oh crystal i mean i've done a fair
amount of reflecting on it um and no it
it it
seemed like i wasn't the right candidate
for this place uh
this time
um i mean i'm proud of the campaign we
ran on some levels we got over 115 000
first place votes a lot more second and
third place votes thank you new york
um more individual donors than any other
campaign in the history of the city
uh and the most important thing is when
i just walk around the streets of new
york uh today yesterday tomorrow people
just are happy to see me you know like
it's a good feeling so you know we felt
we came up short uh you know like we we
weren't the right candidate for this
moment but i'm really grateful for all
of the
support i got in the experiences i had
anything you would do different or you
just feel like you weren't the fit for
the moment
well i'm sure you know obviously if you
come up short then like you
want to do some things differently maybe
you get a different result
the other thing i wanted to ask you
about that which you do talk a little
bit about in the book in the afterword
is in new york city they do have rank
choice voting how do you think that that
played into the outcome and uh what sort
of lessons can we extrapolate from that
to how it might apply at you know the
state and the federal level
a huge ranked choice voting proponent
i'm actually
going to be trying to help promulgate it
all over the place obviously i mean it's
like one of the core tenets of the
forward party and i thought ranked
choice voting in this mayoral primary
was a plus i got to campaign with
catherine garcia uh 95 of new yorkers
found it easy to use 77 want to do it
again and if you get four out of five
new yorkers to agree on something it's
pretty damn good in my my mind says so
uh ranked choice voting should be here
to stay there is a distinction though
between rank choice voting in a primary
which is what we had in new york and
an open primary with rank choice voting
because uh you did shut out a lot of
independents and republicans i had a lot
of people come up to me on the street
and say hey i want to vote for you
i'm an independent uh how do i do it
um and then if they were a registered
voter already they were too late they
needed to change their registration by
february 15th which was more than four
months before the election
so if you had a truly open primary right
towards voting i think that would have
been better but ranked choice voting was
still a plus because it should have
rewarded folks who were willing to
come together and solve problems more
collectively
and i was excited to try and give
katherine a boost down the stretch
you know she was obviously my second
choice
for mayor after myself
yeah and she almost uh almost made it
almost did it yeah that would have been
a great testimonial
like that that was uh yeah that was
happening i was like
that was you know
wild to watch that all unfold um
you know andrew are you optimistic
because i have to say as someone who
covers the news every day and
you know watches
some of the same
failures that you chronicle in your book
the same incentives the same
disappointments
um right now as we're recording this you
know the fate of the entire biden agenda
looks like it may well crumble even
though pieces of it have 80 and 90
support
um the one that i think particularly
rankles is this idea of negotiating
prescription drug prices for medicare
which is literally supportive oh gosh
how are you not doing that yeah it's
crazy how are you not doing it democrats
have been running on this for over a
decade and
still may not ultimately happen so
do you look at that set of facts not to
mention all the tensions that you also
chronicle and the way that we're sort of
intentionally being pulled apart um for
profit by nefarious actors nefarious
institutions are you able to look at
that and still feel hopeful and
optimistic
it it's
awful what's happening uh and i i do not
feel great about the state of our
country or democracy uh crystal i think
you know i'd be lying if i was like oh
yeah i'm feeling great about things um
you know like there's a real
chance of
political violence upcoming in 24 in my
opinion 22 potentially
um
it's one reason why i'm doing what i'm
doing is that if you are honest
and you see what's going on right now
where
democrats theoretically have control of
the government and aren't able to
deliver on various things and we all
know that their hold on power might
vanish pretty quickly
and leave us at a uh a
point that in in some ways um you know
you could argue is uh square one or
maybe worse
uh what is the true answer like and and
so that this is
core to your question because they're
like hey andrew are you optimistic uh i
see myself as
deeply deeply practical and i like to
think clear-eyed if you're clear-eyed
you cannot look at the system and say
yeah yeah this is working like this is
not working for democrats independents
republicans it's driving us all mad
and so in the face of that madness
what is a real answer what is a real
solution
and i believe that
the real solution
is changing the duopoly the duopoly does
not make any sense on its face there's
nothing about two parties in the
constitution it's holding us back in so
many ways 57 percent of americans want a
third party 60 think both sides are out
of touch so if a majority of americans
are at that point why can we not change
it and it's because we've been told we
cannot change it
like that that's really the answer to it
so then you have to say okay
hey if enough of us get together can we
change it well let's do that let's start
the forward party inclusive of everyone
of every alignment don't need to change
your party registration and let's change
the incentives that we'll have real hope
this is my best shot at something i can
feel
great about
because at least win or lose i will have
proposed and championed the thing that
would actually do the trick
you know like that that is my
responsibility my responsibility is just
to be honest with
anyone who i'm you know been fortunate
enough to get your support
or anyone who's listening to this who's
not a yang person but is like what the
hell is going on and what can we do
about it it's one reason why i feel so
strongly about this book
that
uh after i wrote my last book the one on
normal people
i thought to myself this could be my
greatest contribution ever and i would
die happy like you know if i managed to
advance the understanding of the
automation of our economy and universal
basic income and that is my legacy you
can put that on my epitaph and that is
a-okay with me
and at the end of my presidential
campaign
i had you know these emotions because i
was like oh like i fought my ass off and
heart out and i think i might have made
a big difference like you know who can
say that like that's a great feeling but
then i also felt this responsibility
being like oh like the problems are
still getting worse and like i'm i'm
still here and my kids are still here
and like i gotta try and make a go of it
i now think that
forward and this diagnosis of our
problems in our democracy just to let
you all know that you're not crazy
what's crazy is to look at our system
and think it should be working
like it's set up not to work
uh and so if i can help people see what
the real solutions could be
then
this could be
my most
important work or contribution ever um
and so that that's where i am now
crystal like this is a very long-winded
way of answering it's like hey how do i
feel about the future i feel
pretty damn bad
but
um but you know but i i feel like okay
here's a real answer that if we were to
get
our legislators to a point where they
have to answer to 51 of us dilute all
the special interests dilute the
extremity make it so that things that
have 80 90 approval actually pass then
we'd have a shot at it but it's only
possible if we free ourselves of the
duopoly the duopoly is not going to pass
anything that's going to solve our
deepest problems
well you asked me what i thought of the
book i really enjoyed reading it um you
know one of the things that i've always
appreciated about you andrew even when
we've disagreed on various issues or
tactics or whatever it is is i always
you know i feel like you're coming at it
very honestly and that we can have these
conversations and i'll ask you a
question and you'll actually give me an
answer which can be a try my best chris
so i'll try my best
as well so i really enjoyed the book i
thought it had that
characteristic honesty self-reflection
you mentioned that you you know you kind
of think about areas where i could have
done this different or maybe i should
have endorsed in a different way here
and am i balancing these competing
priorities in the right way and
that's i really enjoyed that i enjoyed
the clear-headed focus on kind of like
here are the big problems facing the
country and these little process
squirmishes in the theater in washington
is really not where it's at so
i enjoyed the book i totally recommend
the book i think people who get who want
to understand what
what it actually is like to go through
the meat grinder of a presidential
campaign
and all the ways that you know i don't
want to use the the words rigged but all
of the ways that this thing is
structured in a certain way to generate
certain outcomes um it's very revealing
in that way so congrats andrew
thank you crystal and i gotta say
um i think that running for congress in
a way you did is such phenomenal
perspective i wish that every journalist
who covers politics had to run for
office because you know you just
understand it differently um
and it's one reason i think why
uh people love you so much and you can
do what you do is that you know you you
have your beliefs and convictions but
you also have a sense as to what the
meat grinder is um i tried to convey it
in a way that was interesting
to people but i think that you know i
mean literally there's a chapter in
running for congress where you're like
oh yeah i remember that oh yeah
it's you know it's a different level but
you can kind of relate to some of those
dynamics so um congrats again andrew
where do you want people to get the book
uh if you go to andrew yang.com
there's a pre-order uh link there
there's also a book tour i'm heading to
10 cities around the country if you want
to have a fun night or afternoon you get
a book i'll sign it and then we're going
to have an hour long or so conversation
about the future of the country um so
we'd love to see you out on the trail
but andrew yang.com is the place to go
that's awesome and what are the what are
the first steps for the forward party
look like and where can people find out
more about that at andrew young.com as
well
yeah it's forwardparty.com um but
andrewgang.com obviously has the links i
would love for you to sign up um we're
going to to get to work on campaigns as
quickly as possible
um so if this sounds like something you
want to be a part of people have been
waiting for a third party forever
and then right now with the forward
party they're looking at it being like
hey
can this really fly uh if enough of us
get together we can make it fly very
very high so uh go to forwardparty.com
sign up you know like uh uh buy a
t-shirt like do whatever uh you wanna do
to support but let's fix it let's give
ourselves a real chance um you very
successfully and i know it wasn't just
you the yang gang and the pandemic and
all sorts of good and bad things put ubi
on the map direct cash assistance so um
if you can make ranked choice voting and
open primaries if you can put that on
the map as well that would be doing an
incredible service to absolutely
everyone in this country um thank you
crystal that's exactly the way i see it
ubi was the what open primaries and
ranked choice voting is the how this is
the second leg of the journey and let's
do it thank you so much crystal there
you go great to see you andrew
[Music]
you